vct masters berlin is over and you have
to give it to gambit they were just
better when it mattered most for the
first time since iceland a non-american
team is now in the conversation for best
in the world but we saw so much more in
this tournament we saw good games
throughout we saw the expected champions
crumble to bits and we even saw a little
bit of drama
okay maybe quite a lot of drama don't
worry we'll get to that
all right then if you love this video
then you're probably going to enjoy our
brand new youtube shorts channel where
we upload all the best funny moments and
highlights from the streamers and pros
you love
i'm kind of addicted to it to be honest
it's really good so make sure you
subscribe alright so as the dust settles
now on vct masters 2 let's take a quick
look at how we got here it's been a
crazy few weeks in an even crazier year
for valerian for those of you that
follow the scene closely it might be
easy to forget just how new everything
is in may masters one in reykjavik gave
us the first international vct event in
the game's short history and considering
it was valerian's first major lan event
it went pretty well we saw north america
perform better than expected sentinels
won the whole thing without dropping a
single map and the finals drew in over
one million concurrent viewers the one
was close they don't know oh my god he
gets blessed the team flash the team
flash magnum's in the smoke here oh my
god magnum's got no hp not like this
sentinels they're gonna get the defuse
they've done it sentinels are the
masters to reykjavik champions and they
do it flawlessly they didn't drop a
single map
they have made history here riv because
they are the first global champions in
valor and history in the months since
there's been a lot of hype around
sentinels being the best team in the
world some were quick to proclaim were
living in the sentinels era but others
weren't so sure it's not that sentinels
haven't been dominant they have but come
on iceland was the first major valorem
lan it came at a time when many regions
were still finding their feet and so
some people said you couldn't really
draw broad conclusions about the pro
scene from it when vct berlin approached
though there were no excuses the game
had been out for well over a year we've
seen nine months of official riot
tournaments everyone knew what the deal
was and that's why there was so much
excitement going into this would
sentinels still be number one could eu
surpass n a and what about korea's
vision strikers would they find
redemption after failing to qualify for
iceland before those questions could be
answered though we had the group stage
which did not disappoint let's see if
there's anything left in the tank what
can they bring us here already he's
going to spot out most of the play and
also just takes off oh my keeper's head
the follow-up as well
they're saying pretty he doesn't need to
zoom in
the g2 versus sentinel showdown in group
d was highly anticipated especially
because g2 hired a literal plane to fly
a banner that said
sentinels on it
yeah
but a plane wasn't quite enough to shake
sentinels as tens did typical tens
things to bring them the victory over g2
towards the site good trade to start it
out cold dementa holding close still
only good for the one the operator rises
and tens might just have shown up when
they needed him three kills out of this
young man the server but can kellogg's
ruin it for the side of sentinels
absolutely not despite gambit coming a
close second two hundred thieves in
their group they were already showing
signs that something special was yet to
come 30 seconds left
reset okay make that a 1v2
devo manages to pick up the spike as
well understands he goes there ethan's
going there as well it goes into
aggressive you definitely good for four
looking to work the ace
with the blade storm he go he's gonna
util defoe does it my goodness the ace
to kick off the series for a gambit and
there was even time for a little bit of
memeing when paper rex's ben kai woke up
just in time for a game
[Music]
but the playoffs is where things really
kicked off first let's talk about the
elephant in the room they begin with s
and they also end with s sentinels made
it out of group d along with g2 but
after losing to them the second time the
gods of north america weren't looking
quite as sharp as people were expecting
as the favorites going into the
tournament they were expected to at
least make it to the grand finals but
ended up crashing out to envy in
quarters this was pretty insane if you'd
have said before this tournament that
sentinels would be out in quarters
people would have said there's something
wrong with you some tens heroics to
bring the first game to overtime still
ended in a loss and by the end of the
second game it was clear that envy with
a better team on this day they're all
looking for no opportunities being found
is traded out again
it's all on shazam and it's over it's
done with they say when you come for the
king you best not miss an envy they
didn't
envy had killed the kings of valorant in
semis they continued to wreck their
north american brethren by dismantling
hundred thieves to take them to the
final their dominance was matched only
by gambit on the other side of the
bracket who took down vision strikers in
quarters before facing off against g2 in
semis the first game was close but the
second brought the only 13-0 map in the
entire tournament it was brutal three
players remain g2
being utterly humiliated they'll get
themselves a spike one they'll give
themselves a bit of hope but shadows
looking to drop more players another one
falls it is looking all but over it's
not kellogg's to give them anything and
g2 have been humiliated
as gambit make their way through to the
final and who the hell will doubt them
now the stage was set for the grand
finals on the one side we had gambit
coming off the back of their ridiculous
13-0 win and on the other we had envy
who hadn't dropped a single map in the
tournament so far still nobody could
have predicted just how tight things
were gonna be but can the rest of envy
stay alive that's a bigger thing there's
a tp and now look at finesse he can lock
these players in they have no idea he's
got a round to this spot this is good
for success effortless slicing through
them it could not have been better envy
somehow turning this back around posted
up in hookup
that's the first one to find if he needs
to
still a tricky angle clip not gonna
happen effiness you're a hero you just
got envy to 1212. gambit took the first
map in overtime but envy were undeterred
going into the second with yay pulling
off some frankly inhuman clutches
so good against like sexual js
good
excuse me yay
got a dissolve but it is against big boy
nat and yates gonna get that to halfway
you know it is now nats what are you
gonna do about this though okay that's
the plan okay forces him off if the spam
comes in he goes right back out oh wait
yay what can you do the right click that
he's just doing that what am i watching
what am i watching he's got to defuse
lauren yay but although envy looked
unstoppable at times gambit looked
inevitable they were 2-0 up and you all
know what happened next
i mean oh my god
yeah he's made a meal of it it's all
going to pieces
in the final moments has just shone so
brightly though blinded by the lights
gambin are the valerian masters
champions
you know what it was a sick finals it
was close it was incredibly fast paced
it had back and forth it had everything
you'd want some people were quick to
claim gambit's victory as a win for eu
in their great rivalry versus n.a that
gambit winning was a point on the board
for europe but as average jonas pointed
out on twitter gambit are an emea team
which includes european turkish and also
teams like gambit from the cis region
it's important to make this distinction
not just for na fans who don't want eu
to hold this over them but because the
cis region really deserves the credit
here take na'vi for example the current
kings of cs go they're from the cis even
gambit's counter-strike team were
dominating during the covid lockdown
when there were no lan events while na
and eu have been bickering about who's
best in the fps world the cis teams have
been quietly taking over and gambit's
valorant win is just the latest example
of this and while we're speaking about
both of these games it's a good time to
bring up envy's press conference after
their defeat for those of you that don't
know envy's marved has been wrapped up
in a match fixing scandal from his time
as a cs go pro which is currently being
investigated by esic when a journalist
questioned envy about whether this will
affect their valorum team let's just say
it didn't go down too well
um there are a lot of rumors from the
counter-strike days around match fixing
in the mdl
i'm wondering if that concerns the team
right now if any of you guys are
thinking about that in terms of players
on the team roster changes and so on
we're ignoring it we're good on that one
envy's founder hastro doubled down on
this reply later on twitter saying if
one of our players is proven to have
cheated fixed a match or violated the
integrity of the games we compete in
they will be removed from our team
instantly you journalists don't need to
ask how about you investigate the fbi is
also involved in this investigation so
yeah it's a pretty big deal obviously
we'll have to wait and see if the
investigation finds marv guilty and then
if they do whether or not riot will take
action for improper behavior in another
game like cs go in slightly less hard
hitting drama some people were up in
arms when hundred thieves content
creator and tenzi's girlfriend kai day
called crashy's scrawny on stream after
envy knocked out sentinels in
quarter-finals
[Music]
it's over
there was a lot of backlash on social
media about this with people accusing
kai day of body shaming crashes she
later released a twit longer in which
she apologized for the remarks and said
she'd receive death threats over all of
this which have made her think about
taking a break from streaming before
thanking those who had kept her
accountable for what she says and does
it's safe to say that some people's
reaction to her comment were insane i
know everyone has a different definition
of what toxic is but death threats for
this is completely bat [ __ ] and
incredibly unfair to her one last thing
that i took away from all the action
this weekend was the rising competition
for the title of best player in the
world after iceland 10 certainly stepped
up as the front runner finds the
greatest time ever to backstab through
window and blindside dapper but tens and
company holding on but the response from
cloud9 has been swift as well but since
it's gonna go all the way for the ace
you have to be kidding me but let me
tell you this past weekend ascend cned
and gambit's nats did a lot to say hey
don't forget about us
and especially in a round like this
where there's only gonna be pistols in
play it's gonna become fairly difficult
that's probably the most knives i think
i've ever seen fired off in one go
ever again that just doesn't it makes no
sense it was reloading as he peaked
mixwell
i can't believe what we've just
witnessed get me out come here how is he
not look at his face so where are we now
well gambit's win has secured them a
spot at champions at the end of the year
where we'll see the best 16 teams in the
world battle it out in the major to end
all majors at least for this year they
also earned the emea region a fourth
spot at champions which has resulted in
fnatic qualifying for the tournament and
ascend rounding out the third team
qualified so far and although envy
didn't take home the trophy this time
their second place finish has earned
them enough circuit points to qualify
for champions the other north american
team that has already qualified is of
course sentinels thanks to their
unpassable circuit points earned
throughout the year that leaves room for
one more north american team in the last
chance qualifiers in brazil team
viking's performance throughout the year
earned them enough circuit points to
qualify while keyed stars took the
second spot they actually started berlin
with zero circuit points but then
leapfrogged over every other team in the
region to secure that second spot thanks
to their points from this tournament
southeast asia is sending x-10 and team
secret to champions while vision
strikers and crazy raccoon respectively
will be korea and japan's sole
representatives after dominating latin
america crew esports will be
representing the region while the south
america and aipac regions will have to
wait for the last chance qualifier
tournament in october for now gambit are
the rightful kings of valorum but as
we've seen from sentinels sometimes
these things don't last too long
yeah
am i right
who's
how you guys with me or what that was
crazy you guys
what were they thinking yo
okay i'm done